welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemons here to break down
episode six of She-Hulk for you I almost
forgot how to do six I almost did seven
this episode started a little slowly but
it was a wedding episode and point me in
the direction of a fast wedding mm-hmm
but I thought either way the mid to end
scene gave us a ton of theories as to
who the Hulk King is the Intelligentsia
is here and worse than ever and also
these folks may not be squirrels but
they may be plants I
skit we'll get into it and I'll point
out some stuff I noticed so let's get it
on get it on we opened to a shot of a
pink box glittered with Jen's name it's
framed with blue thistle flowers and
pink thistle flowers the contrast
between the box and the tealish green
box reading flowers brings you back to
Titanium she-hulk's last episode doesn't
it now I've been a bridesmaid a couple
of times and yes the boxes do get more
and more extravagant as you get older
inside the Bridesmaids box is a team of
bride sash succulents heart-shaped
glasses bath bomb lots of bride tribe
junk a letter saying duh of course you
will to be in a bridesmaid not even a
please also glitter is everywhere not
even a Dyson could clean that up as
shulky is packing nicknamed by Nikki not
by me Nikki assist on Jen's bookshelf we
see a lonely planet's book for traveling
to Mexico which she could have had
before or after being in the lab with
Bruce in Mexico we learned this is all
for the family friend Lulu who is
getting married which Chad is also DJing
Chad is just a jack of all trades I
guess like me Jen also mentioned
previously not talking to Lulu anymore
but maybe Lulu felt obligated to ask her
to be a bridesmaid which is kind of
fishy Jen begins talking to us the
audience summarizing the theme of the
episode like we saw in episode one and
three with almost three minutes into the
episode as well there's no specific time
that's best to break the fourth wall but
scenes where you want to feel intimate
with the viewers are always a good place
to start so in this case just making
sure we're all on the same page and this
is a self-contained wedding episode as
soon as Jen steps out of the car we hear
the Vibes playing by Sapphire such a Bop
about switching up your Vibes and
flaunting that new money baby in this
case it's Jen's wardrobe and under
confidence this tiny Barn is going to be
home to what is going to be Lulu's
wedding and if you don't know who Lulu
is this is Patty Harrison one of the
funniest comedians I've ever seen this
show has great Ensemble of comedic
Riders so not surprised they grab some
great la improvisers like these folks
Lulu could be based off Louise Grant in
the comics here after retiring as a
vigilante AKA blonde Phantom worked
alongside She-Hulk and Blake Tower where
they became best friends though they
don't share the same name there could be
a similar energy with the character sort
of how people think Nikki to be Jill
Stevens Jen best friend in the comic who
died we meet their friends Blondie AKA
Heather is played by Mackenzie Kurtz and
the other one on the left is played by
Abigail's Mina let me tell you these are
some Mean Girls just like the movie and
it fits perfectly because the weddings
on Thursday it's a Wednesday and they're
all rock and pink they also mentioned
this toned up for the big day workout
plan which we didn't see in the
invitation box and also just seems
really weird to send your bridesmaids
Lulu pulls genocide to chastise her for
arriving at She-Hulk and taking the
attention away from her but in reality I
think Lulu and this wedding may be a big
plan to help grab Jen's DNA or blood
sample hear me out there's a ton of red
flags you guys one she wants Jen out of
She-Hulk form which is pretty vulnerable
two she invited Jen to her wedding and
they haven't spoken in years even Jen
was a little skeptical also who's the
damn groom where is Adam third I'm sorry
but there's no food at this wedding The
Vibes are a little off at this venue and
I think we can all feel it for Josh's as
Whitney says in our recent Rogue Theory
a Barney Stinson it's too much it's too
easy and it's like what a coincidence
for him number five side note when Lulu
asked Jen if she's dating anyone this
could have been information she needed
to pass to Josh to further whatever
dastardly plan they have I may be
completely wrong I might be theorizing
too hard but I just think we should keep
an eye out because this wedding is very
weird our new title card this week says
just Jen attorney at law and I love it
more clashing between her and She-Hulk
but this time it's like every bit of
confidence boost that She-Hulk needs you
know it's like she takes one step
forward and two steps back oh I'm just
here for it sometimes we're on to our B
story that is Mallory working with our
new client Mr Hollis aka Mr Immortal
played by David pasquesi you might have
seen him from book of Boba Fett so Mr
Immortal is one of the saddest Heroes
because he is cursed with the power of
immortality which you can imagine is
probably horrible every Twilight
character had a horrible life I'll give
you a little bit about Mr Immortal aka
Craig Hollis from the comics he was
first introduced in the 80s and West
Coast Avengers and the 2005 Dan slot run
we learned since he was little death
urge was a part of his life he's
basically like the Grim Reaper death
urge was around usually in bad light to
take people away from Craig in his life
like Craig dad during the fire that he
started and his first love who committed
suicide Craig had tried even taking his
own life many and many times even
pleading death or to take him but he
refused once he aimed to become a
superhero with his powers he found his
calling he also found a team one being
the lightning rods which were made to
mimic the Thunderbolts and once they
found out the Thunderbolts were actually
the masters of evil they sided with
Shield to stop them Mr Immortal can have
a lot of little ties to our MCU story
lines but this Mr Immortal looks like
it's taken a different route but I
wouldn't shy away from Mr Immortal in
the comics his backstory is very Grim
yes but it's an interesting read and I
actually really enjoy it so you should
check it out so we see why Mr Immortal
is there he's been trying to divorce his
spouses but we see he's been dying and
resurrecting himself later I know what
you're thinking can you get out of a
marriage if you die and then come back
to life technically yeah you can in the
eyes of the law a missing person is
presumed dead if they're missing for
seven years or more and the fact that
marriages end at death of a spouse
according to the California Family Code
the marriage is boring if it's generally
believed that the former spouse is a
dead person so Hollis checks both those
boxes but what makes this an unwinnable
case is the intent knowing he can come
back to life at any moment also I just
have to mention he walked into traffic
to get out of talking about his divorce
and in the comics death urge got him to
do that as a child the men on this show
also I'm a good guy if you say you're a
good guy chances are you're not a good
guy Mr Immortal once Mr Immortal jumps
out the window and lands onto Hickman
Security Service vehicle this is for
Kyle Hickman the art Department
coordinator there's also a QR code when
you scan it it takes you to the Marvel
site to a free comic of the West Coast
Avengers number 46. thanks we find out
that not only is Twilight canon in the
MCU but Lulu has dated both Taylor
Lautner and Robert Pattinson which truly
will piss me off if it's true if you're
watching this and you're born in 2006 or
later you probably missed the war that
was Team Jacob and Team Edward and I
think we all know where I stand I'm Team
Jacob sad thing is I took this photo
like two years ago but it still holds up
either way guess who makes an entrance
to the wedding party it's Titania she's
also sporting the loudest outfit
possible with boss earrings so I can't
even be completely mad we meet Josh
played by Trevor Salter and I really
really want to like Josh you guys I
really do I really want everything for
Jen to be good but like this is just too
good to be true right now the next day
we're introduced to each of Mr
immortal's former spouses only a few of
them are credited his ex-wife one two
three and four are played by Heidi Rue
Luciana Scarano Bree Shannon Tawanda
Winston and the ex-husband number one
played by Gregory Nassif St John and one
of them brings up a video of the death
stunt on the Intelligentsia website now
the Intelligentsia and the comics our
first scene in Fall of Hulk Alpha number
1 and was a super brilliant organization
LED at one point by the leader than by
Modoc they originally set their sights
on amassing all knowledge and Intel but
later when they disband and got back
together Modoc LED them to defeat Hulk
and try taking over the world we could
see one if not both characters soon
since we can expect to see Modoc and
Ant-Man and was quantum media and the
leader in the New World Order but this
series is setting the Intelligentsia as
a website the one for hateful man babies
we also got a shot of Nikki's notes
regarding the case where she wrote
things like child support probably in
regards to Spencer Jr and Arnie in
quotes next to New Orleans Jazz Fest she
needs those picks Amy who is married to
Roger so clearly this man was given fake
names fake identity fake deaths this man
surely can't win I just can't allow it
it's the day of the wedding we're back
at the small barn it could be me but I
think these dresses are ugly this this
is a breakdown video so I have to break
down everything you guys including this
wretched scene where they have Jen doing
the groomsmen laundry because they are
playing Mario Kart on their switch what
Heather is trying to get at is Esports
it's basically professional gaming with
those giant tournaments home to ones
like OverWatch League of Legends uh the
balance ones are my favorite this was
actually my first gig when I moved to LA
was working for a giant league
tournament and it was really wild also I
don't care whose wedding it is I'll walk
with that damn dog he is so cute even if
he's leaking and half alive but that's
the animal lover in me the petty
bridesmaid would smack the bride up also
I haven't found anything about Jonathan
the dog in the comics but there is a
Jonathan The Wolverine from Marvel
Comics that's really fun he's like a
giant bear I'm all about attention to
detail it's a nerd thing it's easy to
get to the bra Strokes right but even
seemingly simple things can go from fine
to mind-blowing if whoever is making
them cares about the details right take
coffee for instance it's easy to get a
cup of coffee that's fine but if you
want mind-blowing coffee you've gotta
find some coffee that gets the details
just right and that's where coffee cult
comes in
coffee coal is the closest you can get
to roasting your own coffee beans
without actually growing and roasting
your own beans I caught it coffee coat
sources only specialty grade arabica
coffee beans from all over the world
they work diligently with their Farmers
to ensure the best quality possible
inspect each Bean so that they're never
roasting anything that's less than
excellent and speaking of roasting most
coffee companies don't roast their own
beans and when they do they roast them
in big batches and hope somebody orders
them before they lose that fresh roasted
flavor not coffee Colts coffee coat not
only roasts their own beans but they
roast to order meaning that when you get
your coffee from coffee coat those beans
have been roasted fresh they've got all
sorts of different coffees you can check
out including exotic choices like
Sumatra which has notes of chocolate and
brown sugar
me I like the dark roast perfect for
fall
much better than your average cup of
coffee it's stupid what have I been
doing with my entire life oh if you want
to try coffee coat for yourself go to
coffeecult.com and put in your promo
code new rockstars10 to get 10 off your
order order more than 50 worth of coffee
and you'll get free shipping too oh This
coffee's got me going crazy again that's
coffeecold.com and use promo code new
rockstars 10 for 10 off your order yeah
yeah also additionally if you haven't
are great Partners over the epic hero
shop just released their green Justice
merch line inspired by She-Hulk it's got
several different t-shirt designs
including the newest limited edition
latest Obsession shirt Lady Justice oh
we they're also dropping lines inspired
by the house of dragon Andor and rings
of power when you purchase one of these
shirts you get the opportunity to get a
shout out from Vos Mt or i on inside
Marvel that's pretty swell it's a pretty
small thing just make sure it's
appropriate okay let's get back to the
breakdown when they're trying to come to
an agreement with his former spouses he
mentions his share in apple in 1981
which would be a ton of money by now he
also mentions all the gold left to him
by his first wife baroness Cromwell who
has to be Elizabeth Seymour who was King
Henry's third wife Jane Seymour's sister
so it's safe to assume this dude was
posing as another man who could have
been John Paulette baroness cromwell's
third husband thank you six the musical
or it could be in Marvel Comics the
person also known as Lily Cromwell AKA
bear in his blood since we're getting
into more spooky stuff in MCU I'm fine
with either characters I love history
and I love spooky clearly none of this
works because one wife has a child with
him married to him for three years while
one was married to him for 18 years so
rightfully they start to argue about the
length of their relationship mirroring
the rate that they should each acquire
and Mr Immortal can't jump out a window
for this one baby we're back to the
wedding where Chad is dressed like
Johnny Depp's Willy Wonka the inferior
one his shirt and record box I also wait
a minute quickly don't you fight me on
this because the squirrels was too
stupid squirrels yeah it's gross anyways
his shirt and record box matches stage
name DJ enchetta bull hole and let me
tell you if I became a Hulk I can name
at least 12 people in my family that
would try making money off me Jen
decides to drink herself happy in a
classic wedding Bop Annie Lennox is
walking on broken glass yes it's a
wedding Bop but also the music video is
the scene for also another wedding not
quite the same wedding but the same
start to drink and let loose kind of way
kind of wedding also the support from
Chad in the background is Chef kiss
while Jen is dancing it up Nikki's being
the best paralegal divvying up the money
for Mr immortal's former spouses let's
get into a little bit of it because I
just like drama Sebastian is reimbursed
for the Lake Lawn Mausoleum this is a
New Orleans funeral home so it makes
sense that why it was a jazz funeral
basically Taylor gets two years back pay
for quitting her job to help Paul run a
rare Jade shot green wink wink and
Piedmont which I assume is in California
okay thank you dashel confirmed Cheryl
the mama just getting straight money
baby and Amy gets a sincere apology a
meaningful eye contact lasting at least
15 now 20 seconds which seems like what
she wanted so Kudos Nikki did a damn
good job and people pin it's the flag to
the Philippines I love it Nikki and
Ginger Gonzaga represent baby Jen is
leaving a voicemail for Bruce she's
trying to get a hold of him it's been
weeks months days she doesn't even know
anymore he's just been off world for
that long now I'm no mathematician I had
to go to a lot of my friends for this
but I'm gonna try breaking down how long
it's going to take him to get this a car
and make sure he's not actually still on
the ship so Earth's in the Milky Way and
zakar is allegedly part of the hornax
dwarf Galaxy so that's 450 000 light
years away from us if the speed of light
is 186 000 miles per second you'd want
to turn those seconds into years you'd
multiply 186 000 by 60 seconds in a
minute 60 minutes in an hour 24 hours in
a day 365 days in a year giving upwards
of like 5.9 trillion miles a year if we
were on a shuttle going five miles per
hour it would take 37 200 human years of
travel just that one light year so we're
gonna times that by 450 000 that's over
a trillion years but and that's that's
just human distance but we know in
Guardians of the Galaxy would jump in
and going through wormholes they can
travel 183 light years per second so
divide that by 450 000 then divide that
by 60 seconds we're a little over 40
minutes to travel to sakar so he's kind
of just hanging out not answering his
phone also I don't know that's
completely correct but I went to five
different people we get our second fight
between Titania and Jen but this time
it's personal and Jen is drunk let's
remember that in episode 2 when She-Hulk
changes to Jen it's a different
metabolism so Jen can still get super
drunk during the fight Titania asked if
Jen is not going to turn which I
mentioned before but reminds me of my
favorite fights in the comics between
the two where they're sort of sparring
like fights it's all just personal just
a nemesis and a hero one V1 this is
giving the exact same Vibe Jen Stomps
her foot and makes ripples in the ground
throwing Titania and it's sort of like
the ground pound done in episode one as
the supportive cousin plays Electric
Boogie by Marcia gurfitz that it's
electric I don't think I can sing any
more we get in trouble
yet another wedding Bop not necessarily
a fighting one but I'll allow it Titania
literally eat [ __ ] she literally falls
on the ground and everyone gasps in
unison and I remember during the scene I
went oh
and if you don't know what veneers are
they're literally what every influencer
in Hollywood gets so it makes sense that
Titania would have them by now as
Titania leaves Chad honks this horn
and What DJ has a horn when Lulu sees
Jen as She-Hulk I can't tell if she's
drunk playing it off that it's okay this
is one of the mini faces Patty Harrison
has and I can't read her but it's this
is why I love her so much we finally see
the Intelligentsia website we are the
web and let me tell you it's we see the
trending videos top 10 best travel
destinations the thumbnail features
Cookeville Tennessee my family's from
Memphis Tennessee and when I call my mom
and ask her about Cookville she said
yeah I'm not surprised It's featured on
a website like that so there you go but
also in 1999 Cookville was bombed
causing a Nexus event in Loki episode
two so I think that's more important
than my mom's note 24-hour Loop of
Countryside driving why would anyone
want that [ __ ] She-Hulk and we're
recreating famous artwork that one
sounds fun the video friend Center is Mr
Immortal jumping out of the window onto
the security card titled weird rubber
guy falls off building and lives had to
be taken by that biker dude from this
angle also Mallory and Nikki are
chumming it up drinking 1800 silver
tequila and blatant's Single Barrel
Bourbon okay and also I just love this
broken window behind them that's picked
with wood we also find out Mallory is
married with a child she doesn't have
children or her husband in the comics so
this is new and we can theorize who it
might be all day long but not now I
don't have that much time ain't nobody
got time for that when you try and click
on another video you need to be a member
of the website you must get Hulk King's
approval it also gives us the
hulking wait what the hell the sound is
like the one from Jurassic Park the
Samuel Jackson can't bypass the hacker
didn't say the magic word please now
there is a Hulk King in the comics but I
think this is clearly a nod to the
leader but not necessarily the leader I
think the actual Hulk King will be Todd
who works underneath the leader because
we're getting ready for Captain America
new world order as is to create an
account Nikki deduces you need to come
off as some type of guy using the
account some horrible kind of guy so she
gives herself a username G Hulk sucks
zero zero zero her first name is
anonymous last name a bit LOL no the
city is the internet and the country is
Norway the interests are Bigfoot Bitcoin
USA exercise protein and UFOs I'm into
two of those things try to guess what it
is their bio basically says I'm into
hunting cryptocurrency and some insult
nonsense you get the idea this is just a
woman hating Macho Man waving himbo
lamebow
behind the account sign up we can see
we're on the cancel She-Hulk page so if
you're making a new post it better be
about canceling She-Hulk and an ad for
Pixel plan Cloud there's already some
lame post posted three hours ago about
if she were a man should be canceled
already the top trending channels in the
last frame four hours are She-Hulk at
number one images Heroes movies and
memes of course this site is like a
manhole Reddit and these reactions are
dark I'm not even gonna get into them
because they're just too dark and I
don't want to give them the time of day
before you're like this is too much it's
not realistic I just want to remind
everyone this is sort of basic human
reaction internet trolls have to change
example a our live-action Little Mermaid
they're reacting the exact same way so
it's not too much like I mentioned
earlier the Intelligentsia just wanted
to amass all knowledge and send it
between villains so a heightened version
of that for the MCU would translate to
something probably this dark like the
dark dark Reddit currently Jen is on a
date with Josh I don't know what's with
Jen and getting fries but maybe it's a
good sign that these fries aren't to go
like they were for Arthur because you
know he turned out to be a butthole
either way Jen's enjoying her little
plate with Josh and I'm suspicious of
every man on the show now I think he
could be a plant and maybe Todd and some
of the other men that went on dates
where she holds talk and they're
basically building the right man for her
I'd hate this and I hope I'm wrong but I
just can't trust system right now we see
the whole King message to one of the lab
computers that's diagnosing Jen's gamma
range her macro blood levels we also get
another A113 Pixar reference like in
episode 3. these look exactly like the
same information from the lab when Bruce
was working on Jen but as you can see
this is all Jen Walters records nothing
saying She-Hulk here when I compared it
to the screen in episode one her gamma
is shooting up on Bruce's screen I
posted this one but they can see her
currently on a date with Joss so they're
tracking her by satellite also we get
the names and the credits for the lab
workers Sean Goulding and Justin Randall
Brook who sort of look like the guy
right in the trailer with LeapFrog but I
could be mistaken we see the broken
syringe The Wrecking Crew tried to use
now we don't necessarily know this new
syringe is vibranium shoot it could even
be animanium animanium animanium
animanium adamantium your sounds yours
sounds better they mentioned vibranium
with Todd that my skin is impenetrable
at least with anything on Earth even
vibranium why do you have some on you
you want to test it out but it could
literally be anything they could be just
doing trial and error we get new
courtroom illustrations the gang from
wedding and series of different photo
booth photos Chad kissing the bride Lulu
in one Titania get in her veneers fixed
up she's probably vlogging it the 22nd
direct eye contact and apology to Amy
that's everything I spotted in episode 6
of She-Hulk follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
someone bring me Jonathan Jonathan
[Music]